je suis rentrée ici volontairement
[Musique]
elle a reçu son traitement d'entrée la
nouvelle je passe ce soir l' va
Glé de quoi souffrez-vous je suis pas
malade c'est vrai j'oublie toujours ici
aucune femme n'est
[Musique]
folle je cherche ma mère elle a été
internée ici il y a des
années 29 ans exactement elle aurait 68
ans tuentré pour ça la folie je te fais
entrer aux archives je commencerai par
là si j'étais
toi toujours là où il faut pas
celle-là mesdames comme chaque année à
la même saison se tiendra notre bal
costume
condition vous m à préparer ce B je vous
sors d'ici au premier manquement je vous
y
[Musique]
ramèneir CERN de voleur les
G je avoir besoin de votre aide et tu
peux faire quoi si tu la retrouves je
faire S avec moi
personne peut
[Musique]
sortir